Since word stemming can be kind of an intricate process,
this is something that's usually handles by special functions within
natural language processing toolkits.
Like NLTK, or other types of toolkits that are available in other languages.
Let me give you a quick idea of what this looks like.
So I fire up my Python interpreter and
the first thing that I do is I import a stemmer.
As it happens, there are several different stemmers that are available.
I'm going to show you what the snowball stemmer does.
But there are several others that you might see from time to time.
So this happens to be the command for importing the snowball stemmer.
So I'll go ahead and do that.
I just found this, example on the Internet.
And that usually takes a second or two.
And then what I'm going to do is actually create the stemmer.
And just like with the stop words, I have to declare a language that I
want to stem in, because, of course, stemming a French word will be
different from stemming an English word, we will do English.
Okay, so now I have this stemmer and I can use it to stem any word that I like.
So let's try one of the words from my responsive example.
So I call the stem function on the stemmer that I just created, and
let's use the word responsiveness.
And it gives us that the stem of that is going to be respons.
So something very similar to what we were guessing in the last video.
Let's try another one that's similar.
Same as before, respons, and now I've added a prefix to it, unresponsive.
So it means the opposite of responsive, but
we're still talking about the concept of whether something is responsive or not.
So we should get the same stem still.
We can also see that there are certain limitations to this particular stemmer.
One is that it didn't strip about the un in unresponsive.
And, maybe that's something that you want,
maybe you want to be preserving the information that something that's
responsive and something that is unresponsive are not exactly the same thing.
Maybe all you care about is just the idea that something could be responsive.
So, there can be a little bit of,
of fine tuning here to figure out exactly how you want to run it.
But in general, when you're applying a stemmer,
it's going to clean up the vocabulary of your corpus a lot.
It's going to take something that can be very, very complicated,
you have your tens of thousands of dimensions that correspond to
all the words in the language, and it makes something that's much more compact.
You'll get a chance to
play with this in the mini project at the end of the lesson.